Five, four, three, two, one, transit.
Hey, it's me. Destin. Welcome back to Smarter Every Day. August 21st 2017. It's Matt Whitman,
It's Trevor.
We're in the middle of Wyoming. This is a really special spot. You have to understand
we're on a reservation, and you're not allowed to come here.
- No you're not allowed to come here.
You're just not allowed to come here, but
the Lady that delivered Matt's
son?
-Yep.
Midwife, owns this land. It's a big deal What's a really a big deal
Is that Trevor did the math
We started talking months ago. The international space station is going to transit in front of the eclipse, right?
It's going to happen. This is the spot. Like this is the exact spot
I'll let you know what the farmer said earlier today when we told him that his land was the spot.
This is Mr. Fleming and this is his land. He leases this and he farms it and
You just found out that the space station is going to transit here?
Just found out. Didn't know anything about it.
We had some extra solar film so we set up Mr. Fleming's old binoculars so he could watch the eclipse.
We then took a few minutes and chatted about why we thought Crow Heart, Wyoming
was the best possible place to watch it. You have the best spot in the U.S.
-X marks the spot right here
Yeah, it does so here's the deal
So in Kentucky, they're going to get to see the eclipse longer
Twenty seconds.
Twenty seconds longer
But here you get to see it for almost two and a half minutes and you get the transit of the international space station.
We don't have anybody in Crow Heart, Wyoming.
Really?
No.
But this is a lot of activity for us here.
Really?
Like the most that you've seen in your lifetime?
Yeah, since I've lived here.
And how long is that?
I've been here 30 years.
Yeah.  Are you ready for us to leave now?
As soon as this is over.
*laughter*
We'll get out of your hair, man. [Laughs]
We got Mr. Fleming set up with his binoculars here. So you're good to go
Is that a decent trade, letting us use your land to get your binoculars set up?
Good trade.
(Laughter)
There's good people all over America. You know it.
Oh, yeah.
After 4 hours of setup we were super happy that the clouds cleared out, so we could finally see if the math was right.
Hey come double check my focus if you get a second.
- yeah, we got a minute.
literally
Literally a minute now. 59 Seconds.
You can see the sun spot sharp. That's good.
40.
- 40 seconds
Look at everything and make sure that everything is rolling.
Final touch of my camera.
20 seconds.
Transit.
Oh! It happened! I saw it!
I totally saw it!
Dude!
-Did you see it?
-No, I didn't see it.
-It happened. I saw in the monitors.
-Go back to your recorder.
It happened.
-You saw it?
-I swear. I saw it.
-Six, five, four, three
two, one
Transit.
-Oh!  It happened!  I saw it! I totally saw it!
Dude!
(Music) four, three, two, one.
Transit
There it was!
That is so awesome!
Dude!
Yes!
(Music)
The math worked.
This excitement from successfully getting the transit continued up until the point of the total eclipse where I was so blown away
I totally forgot everything I had practiced.  It was insane. My, my brain was saturated.
This is my shadow band...peice, uh...
Did you come up with something?
-No, no I
-Bump it up.
-There it is.
There they are.
Look at that
That's weird.
-One of the gopros has died.
-That's cool
What?
(Camera clicking)
(Sounds of excitement)
That is crazy.
Oh, my word!
Take your glasses off!
(Kids laughing)
That is bizarre!
The stars!
Oh, wait...
It's overhead sunset.
I had made up my mind ahead of time that no matter what happened with the photography at max eclipse
I was going to drop it all and go spend time with my family
Which is exactly what I did and it was really cool. This is awesome. I did so bad at this
I'm just going to give up.I did so bad. --What do you see?
Look around
That is crazy.
That cool look around behind you
ain't that wild
Look around guys look around ain't that cool
Look at the sun. I love the fact that this was so amazing to me that it just overrode my brain
I just wanted to experience it. I didn't I didn't think about making videos or taking good photos anymore
I just wanted to look at it
20 seconds, I totally bought stuff all about photography. I don't really care
Yeah, here it comes
What?
Wow
Watch it fade on I totally forgot about the drone. I never took my filter off
So yeah, I didn't get good photos. I didn't pull the filters off because I was kind of in the moment
And I really enjoyed it with my family Trevor however did get excellent photos and you can go check those out on his website
I'll leave links below, but man this was this was quite an experience
Do you want a piece of gum?
Would love a piece of gum
What did you think about the eclipse?
-It was awesome
Was it awesome? Cool, thanks for coming with me
-You're welcome
What you think sir?
Well, I want to thank you for these. -Yeah? They made all the difference in the world
Did they really? -Yeah
That's awesome, man -Yeah
Thanks for letting us hang out here!
Pretty weird -Yeah what'd you think? Did you cry?
No, I didn't cry-
You didn't cry? -I was glad to see the old sun come back [laughs]
-a hardened man like you?
'No, I've never cried"
I kind of I kind of got a little weird I got a little weird
Did you get weird? -I got weird.
Do you wanna see the space station transit the sun?
-Yeah I'd love to
*three two one*
*Transit- Oh it happened I saw it!*
-there it was, size of a football field just flew in front
I'll be damned. huh. That's great
Follow my nose. I can't believe how fast that was. -yeah
*-one, Transit- Oh it happened I saw it!*
[Laughter]
I know you normally don't put swears on your videos
But you would be an idiot to leave that off
I'm a professional minister, and I don't think that even counts as a swear because he's a cowboy
What did you think? -I cried, tears of joy I couldn't not cry
Really? -Really. It's beautiful
What'd you think [unintelligible]?
-I get goosebumps
Okay, that's it. I am Destin. This is Trevor-
Trevor where can they find your stuff?
-patreon, patreon.com slash your name my name alright
I'll leave a link below and this is Matt, ten minute Bible hour
That's it the stars aligned, or 'the' star aligned with our stuff. That was cool. Anyway, I'm Destin
You're getting smarter every day. Have a good one
Can't believe my brain quit working. -I can. -Why?
-Weird that you can't believe it. -Really?
It's weird that you're surprised about it. Of course your brain quit working
That was awesome